look
at the wind
guys
let's see look at these poor trees
they're getting wrecked
nah you gotta be a real reporter they go
outside no way
i know but we gotta see we gotta give
him the realness
it's the real vlog channel
thank you for saving me
oh [ __ ] it's [ __ ] cold as [ __ ]
look at the trees over there dude
look at oh my goodness
whoa
so last night we were out here and just
hit the craziest
20 50 miles an hour or something crazy
how many miles per hour was it did you
see 25 miles per hour it was cold i
don't know if it's uh i don't know if
it's you want to go outside monkey
blown away he said are you done
listening
so we couldn't even sleep because it's
just been so crazy windy i hear
something we're not listen you know that
look at the doors they're shaking whoa
yeah uh we couldn't even sleep so it's
like not even
whoa
damn did you just see that whoa
holy [ __ ]
this whole
playground just freaking blew across
damn i came in right in the nick of time
i kind of got impaled by some twigs
barbecue yeah the whole barbecue place
that is over here that's freaking crazy
and then this heavy mat just flew over
here that thing is so heavy it's heavy
dude
where are our bikes wow i don't know
they're probably
they're probably in our neighbor's yard
or something
oh my god
what a way to wake up huh
are you moving back to california
no
no
this is at least cleaning all the dust
away
we needed to rearrange the back anyway
that's true i like it thank you vegas
and it goes
i know
well since it's so early
i asked papa if he could be kind enough
to make us some hot chocolate and the
papa is coming through clutch look at
that he missed a little bit of hot water
so we're boiling some here
because our boiler ran out
so this is actually been boiled
while the dude is beat boxing
hey cutie
i like your pjs
papa
is doing the mama's job of washing the
dishes
oh is that right
is that right
all right and mama is doing the papa job
by getting all the stuff from the top
shelf you know
because the dad's supposed to be the
taller one in the family
touched
we got him baby we got him
oh
good
that's why you don't punch it why did
you punch it
nah yeah you should that hurt right
that's why no one else punches it
you okay
now we watch encanto on disney plus
that's a duty thank you papa oh
oh you bikini
you guys are the best together
and then just an update everything's
blown
outside
it just keeps blowing
yeah
we'll see where that goes
okay so we all assume the position
papa's
but we didn't make it past 30 minute
mark watching encounter whoa
see that
i know
[Music]
so now we are out on some blm land
some government owned land where you can
do whatever the f you want so the guys
are just
yep so tiger put some wood in the
little fire pit and then the fire gonna
beat him up yep and the guys over there
set up targets all the way over there
we're gonna do some shooting
yeah peggy's gonna watch he's got his
little headphones i'm not gonna watch
okay we'll see about that
[Music]
yeah i'll put them on for you once we
start shooting but we're not shooting
yet yeah so we're just chilling here
because it's really cold super windy i
think it's like about
what
the flavor we need the water yeah the
fire's beating the wood up yeah look
yeah the fire always wins duty that's
you gotta be careful with fire okay
fire is devastating yeah not ones are
not running yeah
the wood never went against fire they
saw that no
that was cool yeah that was cool how i
did that the wind i think
yep
all right so while the guy shoots
back there
taika and i have been collecting
different items to burn look at that
yeah yeah
yeah we will you wanna put in there now
okay let me see
okay let's see what happens
okay move move
[Music]
crazy huh
that looks crazy
super cool huh
oh okay okay papa
we have a line here a line of safety i
like that good job we're not going past
that but you're taking a break from
shooting how's it been it's been super
cute because i love shooting i love
being in the outdoors but it's rare to
have my family and shooting together
we can do it what does it do is
[Music]
[Music]
so before we even started shooting or
anybody started shooting he had a safety
what did you call it a safety brief a
good old-fashioned marine corps safety
brief where we start off talking about
certain commands cease fire
where to load your weapons which
direction to shoot when you're done
figure off the trigger on safety gun
point either at the ground or down range
just some basic stuff to go over so that
because there's so many people here so
we really want to manage our safety
and we have a lot of shooting
differences and experiences but we're
shooting out with all of the marine
corps boys we don't really have to do
that because it's ingrained in us but
since i have my family here it's that
much more important to make sure we're
doing things the right way cuny okay
you're gonna get okay taka you and papa
gonna go get boxes to burn yeah i just
got one yeah good job okay go get more
boxes but don't step on the line
[Music]